voilà ça c'est michel samimi le rôle ou
michel aussi fait de la magie fapa de la
piste quand il est heureux
salut aujourd'hui je suis avec artus
salue aujourd'hui je suis avec vous
c'est la première fois qu'on présente
merci au début quand j'ai lancé ses
vidéos les potes il venait chez moi je
faisais une vidéo avec eux et maintenant
comme ils veulent plus venir
je viens les voir en fait je frappais et
puis tu ailles ponctuelles s'agit quand
même l'annoncé aux gens ça fait le tour
de paris pour venir chez moi mais c'est
parce que là on est on est dans quoi on
était là on est dans le 6e 6e et moi je
me dis je ne suis pas les plus probables
moi je je leur dis me donnes pas ton
adresse je suis mentaliste j'ai toujours
réglé
voilà j'ai fait trois fois le tour du
sixième je me suis retrouvé lundi du
xviiie je ne savais pas du tout ce qu'on
allait faire avec arte sur l'ordi et je
me suis dit tiens voilà un médecin ça se
voit d'ailleurs puisque encore cela les
tomates est reparti en plein travaux et
un plein travaux et du coup tu fumes non
c'est pas bien non mais plus de
cigarettes électroniques avec de la
nicotine c'est ça et sans électricité je
souhaitais contre c'est la planète tu
peux en prendre une
est ce que tu veux la lui mais s'il te
plait bien sûr va voir là on va voir là
on va voir là c'est pas mal plus de 10 a
dû regarder les 20 heures c'est sa
première de la journée tu pas beaucoup
non plus je vois jamais ni non
on peut parler maintenant tu connais la
méthode coué ou pas voilà qu est la
méthode coué cui méthodes de succès
actuellement
eh bien on va essayer de faire les
méthodes du cou et l'a terminée mais
plutôt par la jeunette de ce côté là pas
de souci je change de place j'ai mes
petites habitudes qui va tendre le bras
gauche comme ça en essayant de rester
dans le champ ah ça c'est super là on
est bien là rien et tu vas me passer ta
cigarette serait utilisé en cas de
l'égoïste ambiance un peu plus depuis le
13 mars 2014 et et tu vas répétez après
moi ça ne voulait pas ça me brûle pour
cent mille poissons construire ça ne
veut pas ça ne veut pas ça ne veut pas
ça ne veut pas ça ne veut pas ça ne veut
pas ça veut pas sachez enfin que ça
chauffe un peu maladroit je t'explique
pourquoi ça chauffe quand même ça
chauffe parce que dans ton champ de
vision périphérique tu vois le point
d'impact
d'aspect et du coup tu anticipes la
douleur et la chaleur donc on va le
refaire
j'espère pas la fin mais y'a longtemps
s'auto parole
oui c'est bon allez première partie
c'est quoi je regarde pas non j'ai caché
dont on ne verra pas le point d'impact
partions ne bouge pas la main ça
pourrait être dangereux en effet aller
ça brouille pas ça veut pas ça veut pas
ça veut pas ça veut pas ça veut pas ça
veut pas ça veut pas ça veut pas ça veut
pas ça veut pas mais là ça fume un petit
peu tu vois alors si j'ai créé ce pas
cette victoire n'a pour l'instant ça va
écoute on l'a bien tout écraser tu vas
mettre son autre main comme ça et tu
places l'ensemble parle par dessus comme
ça reste il faut pas que tu bouges c'est
important ce qui bouge pas je vais
peut-être et tu répètes encore sa
bouille pas ça veut pas ça veut pas ça
roule pas sur l'or
voici ce qui va se passer artus à 3 et
seulement 1 3 tu va écraser doucement ma
main contre l'ami tienne tu va écraser
doucement la main contre la tienne en
lui
ça n'a jamais volé je n'ai jamais fumé 1
2 3 ça n'a jamais brûlé
je n'ai jamais su promettant tu peux
ouvrir les mains tout doucement donc
rien d'anormal on trouve pas de
cigarettes à dire que tu n'as jamais
fumé net je peux manger pas prévoir par
terre cherche aussi dis donc tu as
regardé un film c'est vrai qu'on va le
voir toute la vidéo
alors oui j'aime la camisa c'est les
anges de la télé réalité se freine
street mais c'est parce que j'ai en fait
je comme je bossais sur l'ordinateur
j'ai mis ça en font mais je regardais
pas vraiment de toi non celui qui parle
met vraiment sa toile à regarder et la
caisse consorts là ça serait pas là on
peut le faire
merci beaucoup alors artus il est en
spectacle en ce moment en tournée il est
toutes les semaines à paris du fait de
boltzmann oui que j'avais fait
d'ailleurs je vous mettrais un lien dans
la description il ya toujours la vidéo
en ligne
il ya toujours la vidéo on est un
concept vraiment drôle puisque ont fait
chacun notre sketch et après on reprend
le sketch de l'eau dont la solidarité et
au hasard et c'est moi qui tu avais tiré
au sort d'ailleurs lui c'était vraiment
le cas le héros fait le les ventes
atteignent drôle si il avait une idée
tellement rouge en fait que jamais j ai
pensé mais c'était tellement bien de
reprendre le même genre ben oui c'est ça
il a repris les mêmes gens donc hilare
deviner les mêmes jeux télé on peut dire
j'écris nouveau spectacle tout à fait
qui va s'appeler il était une fois artus
puisque c'est sur les légendes et les
contes il m'a fait lire un petit peu les
le titre le site the thing pour
l'instant je l'écris que le titre écoute
on a tous dit qu'ils voulaient dire un
truc en plus qua non bisous bisous ça
c'est beau et camp danois rendez-vous à
demain 17h pour le prochain mandat le
blog ciao